good morning i am brett Smith as I'm
pointed out one of the graduating
deacons who is speaking today I started
here in 2002 not knowing this church and
not knowing a lot of things about this
college I was football player so by
Sundays we spent getting ready for JV
games or watching film all day long and
not coming to the coming to church um I
was not here for the things the second
semester which would have made it
possible for me to come to the
University church I only had a brief
stay at this come school for the first
time here first time I was here I came
back in two thousand eight after a long
absence from this university I came to
the first service I could over the
summer I will make sense why in a second
I did so and met the associate pastor
close to you Isabel she was very
welcoming to me and she listened to
after the service to part of my story as
i like to call it now i'm at coffee hour
and she remembered what had happened she
came after the accident which was
interleague 2003 but she remembered
cynthia Terry on the associate pastor
before Callista talk about it Cynthia
would often talk about the accident that
killed four young men who all went to
Yale I was in that accident and I am
followed as a fifth fatality luckily I
was only in a coma but a very bad coma
at first Cynthia Terry baptized me after
in my coma after she had learned from my
parents then that I had never been
baptized my family went to church a lot
but because my dad was in the Air Force
we never settled down in church for very
long because we do not we did not know
how long would actually stay
that area um I was baptized by the
university the university church and I
have had and will continue continue to
have an immediate connection every time
I step foot in it for that reason it is
like my home that is why I wanted to
come back as soon as I could to get more
involved with this church in 2008 I came
to my first Sunday back here and i have
been hooked ever since it did not take
me long to get more engaged in this
church as soon as i get readmitted in
two thousand in September of 2008 Glissa
asked me to be one of the student
beacons and i graciously graciously
accepted and i have been a deacon ever
since now i stayed in front of you on
the eve of something that seems so out
of reached in two thousand so out of
reach in 2003 me walking across the
stage to get my yel degree I've learned
a lot over my time at Yale and somewhat
lessons I learned trying to get back to
this great University and I want to pass
them with that knowledge on to you Mike
attended my extended family the Yale
University of church first do not ever
give up on anything when someone tells
you that you can't do something and you
feel that you can listen to listen to
yourself and do it you need need to look
that person in the eye and say to him
him or her either in your heart or out
loud watch me I can do anything I set my
mind to and the Bible it says in Psalms
46 first one God is our refuge and
strength a very present help in trouble
when something seems impossible just
know that God is always right there you
may not see him but he is leaving your
path I am reminded of a poem that is
entitled footprints by an unknown author
in the poem a man has a dream
that he is walking on the beach with the
Lord and up above scenes from his life
or flesh or flashing before their eyes
in the sky when the last scene came
flash before the their eyes he looked
back to see the footprints he was
puzzled by when I was sorry he was
puzzled because one of its when the
hardest scenes of his life flashed upon
upon the sky there was only one set of
footprints yes the Lord why in his
toughest moments the Lord left him the
Lord looked at him said I love you I
would and I would never leave you when
you see only one set of footprints it
was then that I carried you there there
were many times in my life when I wanted
to give up but I kept pushing forward
with Bible verses like Psalms 46 am I
and in this poem and back to my mind to
remind me that God is always right there
sometimes check carrying you when the
way seems too hard the second lesson
that I want would like you to know is
when one way does not work find another
I cannot find a good bible verse 2 quite
cashless feeling so I will draw on my
own experience to show you many times I
would come to a roadblock that seem
insurmountable insurmountable and
sometimes I still have this times but
take for example my feeling in 2003 that
I could come right back to you i'm yael
right brass the accident i was unaware
at that time of all the damage that was
done that had been done to my brain i
had to go back to a community college it
first give my brain a chance to heal
then after a few years I felt like I was
ready to make my return back to the
University earth to this University
you have to learn sometimes to retrace
your steps to back up a little bit and
go down a different path it's like going
through a maze in one of those maze
books we've all gone down the wrong way
at some point or another in those maze
books but if we turn around knowing that
that way when I work and find a more
suitable path we will get out of that
maze just like you will get flying the
way out of any situation that just seems
too hard the last lesson that I would
like to tell you about I will take right
out of the Bible it is from proverbs 3
verses 5 and 6 it says trust in the Lord
with all thine heart and lean not unto
thine on our own understanding and
always acknowledge him and he shall
direct thy paths die pass we do not know
why a lot of things in our lives happen
but if we let God do his work and we
fight with him good things are bound to
occur I cannot believe my time but this
university is coming to a close it seems
like only yesterday I walked through
those doors not knowing what to expect
in this church in 2008 I did not know
people would be nice or if they would be
sort of me nor really not care but
everyone that I've met here and has been
so compassionate they've been
warm-hearted and just a general joy to
be around I will miss my time here lots
of good memories took place with it
within these walls and I thank you as a
contra congregation for letting me be
one of your deacons for the last four
years it has been amazing thank
in the past few weeks I've seen many
less less classes last papers last Club
dinners last debates and this past
Friday my last trip to ian's house for
the annual liturgical olympics this is
awesome at a time to look back at first
I first came to worship service at the
university church on a bit of a whim it
was the sunday of camp yell just after I
turned in a disastrous French placement
exam I did not know what the word Deacon
meant or what made the university church
distinct besides its central location
much of my faith background consisted of
my mother compelling me to go to various
Chinese language Baptist churches and
fitting with my history major I used to
sneak out of worship service as a kid
just before the pastor began to sermon
to read about biblical history in the
church library what a difference 44
months MIT makes now that I am more
active in a faith community than I could
have imagined when I arrived and yet
then as now one thing remains the same I
left an exam looking for relief from my
first bit of work stress as an
undergraduate and since then I find out
my religious life has bounced against my
focus on academics careers and other
material pressures evening prayer for
instance has been a time of solace in
the middle of the work week always
reminding me that church can be more
than just 10 32 1140 on Sunday mornings
and in a world of hierarchies and
deadlines which I admittedly live in
breathin being among the student deacons
and their collective leadership has been
refreshing church has not just been a
way to leave my home work or ladder
climbing
so forgive my use of a thesis but my
time in the university church has begun
to reveal to me that faith in god and
his gifts intrinsically bounces and
keeps my worldly work structures and
goal setting in a much larger
perspective at the end of my time at
Yale I've been meditating on my values
how I've changed what I've learned and
how my faith ties into all that I've
womp rat this delay gratification and
risk aversion believing that I could
achieve my goals before others in
control my destiny because I was
meticulous and willing to limit myself
and fussy things like friendship and
smell them the Rosens early in my junior
year I ended up soul searching about the
purpose of my work in my post-college
path now my self-doubt was broader than
just a particular line of work and study
like law I doubted my approach as a
student and I feared how so much of my
life is outside my control coming a few
months after my baptism here which was a
high point for my spiritual life I was
at a low point as I even grew
increasingly inactive among the student
deacons my time of existential confusion
is now behind me it was through the
friendship of many in my life including
those here that I gained the confidence
to be where I am today knowing where I
will work continued my faith journey and
trying to contribute one last time to
this church why I still can as I
reflected there in the Lenten journey I
consider knowing where I will be after I
graduate one of God's biggest gifts to
me I will always continue to learn but I
hope I understand a little more that the
uncertainty of life in God's gifts I
still feel the tug of delayed
gratification and over planning but I
remind myself as much as I love order
and efficiency it takes more than just
that to be a full child of God being in
the real
rolled over the summer and seeing people
live their lives holistically made me
more aware of my own mortality I'm
becoming more comfortable with the
unpredictability of life that so much is
outside of my control that life is too
short that life is too short to be set
entirely on ambition is not a cliche if
it is true that may seem odd from
someone who is going to ambition driven
line of work but I'm not suggesting I'll
be any less of a workaholic I will still
work hard but that will be more for the
experience enjoyment the gift of working
for its own sake than for the ends more
importantly I will try to be less
distraught if insurmountable obstacles
stop me short of my goals my work is
only a necessary but insufficient
condition for life and things like Fran
family and friends are also essential
being close to family and friends is not
about fulfilling goals is about the
continuous experience at being human
knowing my mortality and realizing that
work is not everything made me more
willing to take risks from romance to
being socially more spontaneous work
alone cannot sustain the love loyalty
and friendships here in places like the
university church that give it so
generously now that I try to live more
in the present I see God manifest not
just in his big gifts but in small ones
as well after more hiatus more than
three years I'm finally returning to my
old hobby in drawing and painting and
I'll delight in these creative gifts
beyond their function as achievements
additionally for every sketch of us
still life or figure I now also
appreciate god's more momentary
manifestations as I jog up Science Hill
in the late afternoon I see that God is
in these little gifts God is in the
breeze rustling the tree branches and
God is in the Rays and the Sun dripping
down on east rock there I see the mat
physical manifestation of Isaiah's words
it is he who
it's above the circle of the earth who
stretches out the heavens like a curtain
and so I see an intersection between the
three aspects of my life work people in
spirituality work in people or of the
temporal world yet they are also gifts
of God and ways to come closer to him
this church community is made up of
people and has been the foundation of my
spiritual life my work is inextricably
bound with cooperating with other people
but careers are also gifts of God I'm
still developing my faith my
understanding of God and my mortality
remains vague but I hope to have that
faith for the rest of my life Isaiah 40
23 to 28 Matthew 6 8 in Psalm 23 that
passages that I have thought about for a
number of terms he remind me why I
should ever worry less and appreciate
what God has given me more referring to
the principles of the world Isaiah or
States dead God scarcely that scarcely
are they planted when he blows upon him
and they wither Isaiah writes lift up
your eyes on high and see who created
these and the Lord is the everlasting
God the creator of the ends of the earth
if Prince's the strongest of humans are
saplings before God and how can I
believe that I can create things without
God life is uncertain and only God knows
my destiny looking at Matthew I do
consider those lilies of the field how
they do not labor and spin and how they
are more resplendent and even King
Solomon though I fell every day I try
not to worry about tomorrow for tomorrow
will worry about itself and I must first
seek his kingdom finally sound 23
reminds me that the Lord is truly my
shepherd just as he has been the
shepherd of this church the green
pastures and still waters are among the
sublime manifestations of God that I see
when I smell those roses through my
worries are mundane compared to the rest
of the world I know he is with me with
his rod and his staff
as I walk through the darkest Valley I
shall strive to dwell in the house of
the Lord my whole life lon the gifts of
God are ultimately his and I am grateful
for all the joy they had given me I
could kill over now and at least
partially be at peace not merely because
of a list of accomplishments but because
the close bonds that I've made of people
and because of my faith in the eternal
afterlife so if that thank you to the
University church to Ian to Calista my
fellow deacons and to everyone who has
supported me and encouraged me to better
understand my spiritual life and my life
in general for that I shall be forever
grateful and we miss you all dearly
thank you